our plan is to protect life and to
protect the NHS both by slowing the
spread of this virus to flatten the
curve and by ensuring that the NHS
always has more capacity to provide the
critical care for those in need
now this is a national effort and every
single person in this country can play
their part in this plan this Easter will
be another test of the nation's resolve
it's a time of year when people normally
come together but however warm the
weather however tempting your local
beach or Park we need everyone to stay
at home because in hospitals across the
country NHS staff are battling day and
night to keep desperately sick people
breathing and they need you to stay at
home I'm very happy to report that the
Prime Minister's condition continues to
improve he wants to personally thank the
whole clinical team at San Thomas's for
the incredible care that he's received
his thoughts are with all of those
who've been affected by this terrible
disease the NHS is there for all of us
in this country and I know our amazing
NHS staff have given the Prime Minister
the very best care possible
in the same way that they would give
every single person in this country the
very best care possible one of the
things that makes me proud of this
country is that it doesn't matter who
you are the NHS is always there to care
for you before updating you on our plan
I want to share the latest data from the
ongoing monitoring and testing program
yesterday I'm glad to report that 19,000
116 tests were carried out across Great
Britain
7706 tested positive the number of
people currently in hospital with
coronavirus symptoms is nineteen
thousand three hundred and four of those
who've contracted the virus eight
thousand nine hundred and fifty eight
have sadly died an increase of 980 since
yesterday we never forget that behind
this number behind each one is a name a
loss and a family that will never be the
same again and we all share a
responsibility to tackle this virus
first and foremost by staying at home
now earlier this month I outlined our
five pillar testing strategy and I'm
glad to report a very positive response
to setting out the goal of a hundred
thousand tests a day by the end of the
month I can announce today that we have
capacity for all key social care staff
and NHS staff who need to be tested to
get those tests to deliver this in
addition to the testing being done in
NHS hospitals
we've now opened 15 drive-through
testing centers including in Glasgow
Cardiff Belfast Nottingham Plymouth
Leeds and London and other places the UK
life sciences industry is also answering
our call to arms
yesterday I opened our first of our
three lighthouse mega labs in Milton
Keynes two more on track in Cheshire and
in Glasgow and AstraZeneca and GSK two
of the biggest pharmaceutical companies
in the world are opening another in
Cambridge and I want to thank the team
and all the volunteers who are working
night and day to make this happen
today I want to address what we're doing
to make sure that we have enough PPE
protective equipment and to make sure
that it gets to the right people the
goal I've set is that everyone working
in a critical role must get the PPE that
they need NHS and care staff protect us
every day while we're safe at home they
go off to work
to care for us we owe it to them to get
them the kit they need to protect
themselves i want to be frank about the
challenges our plan is designed to
overcome first there is a huge
international demand for PPE and a
global squeeze on supply compounding
this some countries have placed export
bans and other restrictions on PPE as
they look to circley all their domestic
needs next there's high demand for PPE
from within the UK so everyone should
use this equipment use the equipment
they clinically need in line with the
guidelines no more and no less then of
course there's the challenge of
distribution the sheer quantity and type
of PPE needed has radically changed
because of coronavirus many parts of the
NHS and Social Care have never had to
rely on weekly PP deliveries before in
normal times the NHS supply chain for
protective equipment supplies 233
hospital trusts right now 58,000
separate health and care providers need
PPE so we've had to create a whole new
logistics network essentially from
scratch all of these change challenges
around supply around usage and
distribution are being overcome and I
want to take a moment to set out in
detail how today we're publishing our
PPE plan it has three strands strand one
is about guidance being clear who needs
PPE when they need it and who does not
there's enough PPE to go around but only
if it's used in line with our guidance
we need everyone to treat PPE like the
precious resource that it is that means
only using it when there's a clinical
need and not using more than is needed
last week following extensive
consultation with the medical rural
colleges all four UK government's
published updated guidance for what PPE
to use in what circumstances the new
guidance included the clinical advice
that many items of PPE can be used for a
whole
session not be changed after treating
each individual patient everyone is
still protected but there's enough PPE
to go around the guidance is also clear
where PPE is not needed because outside
of health and social care in most
circumstances the best way to protect
yourself and to protect others is to
regularly wash your hands and wherever
possible to keep at least 2 meters
between you and other people when you
leave your house and of course the most
important way to protect yourself is to
stay at home because a front door
is better than any face mask the second
strand of our PPE plan is about
distribution making sure that anyone who
needs PP you can get it and at the right
time this is a Herculean logistical
effort we've brought together the NHS
private industry and the army in fact
the Armed Forces to create a giant PPE
distribution network on an unprecedented
scale battle network is now delivering
daily to our frontline heroes quite
literally since the start of the
outbreak we've now delivered over for
over seven hundred and forty two million
pieces of PPE to the frontline this
includes a hundred and sixty 1 million
masks a hundred and twenty seven million
aprons a million gowns and 345 million
pairs of gloves these have reached
hospitals ambulance trust GP settings
social care hospices and community
pharmacies we've also set up a 24/7
hotline for any providers experiencing
supply problems and crucially every NHS
hospital has received a delivery of
critical PPE once every 72 hours and
over the next week we're making that
daily this week we've arranged a
priority drop of 30 million items of PPE
to the local resilience forums the L RFS
are in turn delivering to social care
and others according to local need and
in the coming weeks we'll be scaling up
our PPE delivery systems
still further I can announce that over
the next three weeks we're rolling out
an online portal allowing primary care
and social care a system so that they
can request PPE from a central inventory
and this will mean that we can track
demand in real time and deliver
according to need this Herculean effort
of enormous operational complexity to
get the right piece of equipment to the
right person at the right moment I pay
tribute to the enormous efforts of all
those who are making it happen we will
do everything we possibly can to keep
improving this but I want to take a
moment also to say thank you to all
those involved the third strand is about
the future supply which is making sure
that we've got enough PPE to see us
through the crisis we're using up PPE on
an unprecedented scale so we're
constantly buying more from abroad and
now making it at home our PPE sourcing
unit is securing new supply lines from
across the world ensuring that we but
what we buy meets rigorous standards and
this include teamed from the Foreign
Office the department or international
trade out in the Far East especially
buying directly from manufacturers and
teams in Whitehall focused on rapid
freight operations to get it here we've
published the standards that will buy
against along with our global shopping
list it and it's also about ramping up
domestic production as well going into
the crisis we did not have a major
domestic PPE manufacturing industry so
like with ventilators and with testing
we're creating one many businesses have
generously come forward with offers to
turn over their production lines as part
of this national effort in particular
that I want to thank Burberry with their
offers of gowns rolls-royce of McLaren
who are creating visors in EOS and
Diageo who are producing hand sanitizer
we're talking to many others and we want
more to step up to the plate so if
you've got production facilities and you
can meet our published technical
specifications we want to hear from you
so that we can make this
kit here in Britain that'll keep people
safe this is our comprehensive PPE plan
to protect the people who protect us to
make sure they have the kit they need to
do their job safely and with confidence
but I want to finish by saying this even
if you're not directly involved in the
NHS in the PPE supply chain and testing
or as a key worker there is something
that every one of us can do to play your
part in the national effort stay at home
because spreading the virus today risks
lives tomorrow and it increases pressure
on those who work in the NHS do it for
them
do it for the people who you love the
more we all follow the rules the faster
we can lift these restrictions and get
back towards normal life thank you to
all those of you who are already doing
your bit as part of our national effort
stay well stay at home protect the NHS
and save lives